[Music]
my dad he
died and the solicitor of your father's
estate my dad owned this
place I don't have any memories with him
this is all I have right
now if you're watching this then I'm
already
[Music]
dead this property comes with a special
te
it you're the one thing that stands
between her and the outside world you're
joking what is that come out come out
wherever you
are
Iris we shouldn't be
here
what is
she she has the power to bring back the
Dead I want to see her money's really no
object I want to talk to my
wife she only gives you 2
minutes SAR after that she's in
control what's going
on we are not safe
here how do I control
her this isn't something you can
control I'm going to kill you you can't
kill
her you cannot let her out of the
[Music]
basement
a